hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde gestern war ich in Frankfurt ist
für mich wirklich die zweit schlimmste
Stadt in Deutschland ne auf der Eins
unheimlichten Berlin aber auf der zwei
ganz knappe hinter Frankfurt ich
schwör's euch ich bin seit 3 Minuten
hier habe ich schon wieder alles gesehen
fehlt nur dass wir vorne gleich ein Elch
irgendwie Elefanten oder so ich fahre
mit diesem Zug in den Frankfurter
Hauptbahnhof rein zu bleibt stehen ich
stehe an der Tür drück auf dieses grüne
Ding
Typ ich dir die Treppen runter und was
das erste was ich sehe ein 70-jähriger
Mann mit einer Trompete spielt völlig
krumm und schief und ist dabei nackt
dann dachte ich mir mensch das ist so
eine super Gelegenheit
zu spielen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich muss mit meiner Maus hier spielen
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
[Musik]
[Applaus]
spielen wir mal happy Birthday ich gebe
alles
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er kann nicht mehr aber ich kann die
ganze Zeit gedrückt halten
wahrscheinlich ich muss Pause machen mit
der Luft holt
[Musik]
das Kacke wir spielen ein anderes Lied
Beethovens Fünfte Melodie das soll ich
safe hinkriegen Beethoven und ich sind
so ne oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
[Musik]
das war richtig gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine kleine Nachtmusik es ist von Mozart
mit dem war ich jetzt nicht so dick oh
mein Gott
[Musik]
vier Mal nein
sie soll angeblich nicht ganz so
schwierig sein wie die anderen die ich
gerade oh Gott
sehen 10 Sekunden später
hey irre dass sie darauf früher
abgegangen sind ne
die dachten sich so boah neuer Bagger
von Christopher Waltz oder der heißt
Mozart Beethoven keine Ahnung von mir
das jetzt
und dann sind die darauf so gedämpft
Fortnite Dance ausgepackt
rumgeknutscht im Club oder einer Scheune
früher oder im ritterraum keine Ahnung
was Bruder an der Stelle will ich das
heutige Video jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben Freunde wie bereits
gesagt habe ich einfach am Frankfurter
Hauptbahnhof und Trompetenspieler
gesehen und dachte hey das kann ich auch
kann ich nicht
wenn es euch denn noch gefallen hat dann
lasst gern einen Daumen hoch unter
diesem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke um neue
Videos nicht zu verpassen denn morgen
geht's weiter mit einem neuen Video ne
tschüss
[Musik]